[Music]
well there are other things going on too
because there's twister theory now you
see that's I don't usually talk about it
in interviews because it's it hard to
explain but that's an idea which I had a
lot of people working on when I was at
my graduate students had a lot of
graduate students and many of them work
on Twista theory which gives a different
different point of view how hard to do
view physics if you like see usually we
think of space time when space is 3
dimensions and then time is another one
so you've got this space time which is a
four dimensional structure and the basic
thing it's made of are these little
points we call them events you see no no
dimension in space no dimension in time
the but you see like that those are the
points in space-time of events now you
see you twist a theory that's not the
basic structure the basic thing is
basically but something like a photon
it's it goes along with the speed of
light and you can identify the points
because you have a family of them going
through that point it's sort of it's a
kind of geometry which turns the
ordinary way of looking at physics
inside out some things are more
difficult to do something is a lot
easier to do and what's a lot easier is
to describe feels like the Maxwell feel
filament radiation the gravitational
field in fact gravitational field well
there's a story here you see photons can
spin left-handed or right-handed and you
can describe the wave function of a
left-handed or right-handed one and
usually you add them together because
they both spins combined together to
give you the linear polarization so
things you know polarized glasses you
have they let the light through one way
and not the other way and these and you
add to what right-handed and left-handed
together to get the linear polarized
then they're different ways of doing it
anyway that's the way photons work now
we see in twister theory it's very
peculiar you have a two different
formula one which works for the
right-handed one which works for the
left hand and for the gravitons that is
the particle of gravity if you like
again you do this but you see with
gravity
you want to make it fit in with
Einstein's theory so change your space
space-time is changed by the gravity and
then you find you can do it and you can
do it for the left-handed ones but not
for the right-handed ones and this was a
great puzzle to me because what twister
theories got a twist to it so it's left
analyze are not quite the same in the
theory and you could do the left-handed
ones are not the right-handed ones and I
used to call this the googly problem
because in cricket
you see a ball a cricket ball and if it
spins what's the thing called a leg
break then if it spins left-handed
that's a leg break if you're very clever
though many people can do it you can
make it spin looking as though it's got
left-handed but actually spins
right-handed and that's what's called a
googly so we call this the googly
problem because you're trying to get the
right-handed graviton in the framework
which does the left-handed one and that
was a stumbling block which took about
40 years and only fairly recently I had
an idea with some help from Michael a
TIA who have got ideas from write often
and I had sort of part of the idea and I
can quite understand the other part
which he explained and even then it took
another five years to make it work
but I think it works so this is a way of
describing physics in this unusual way
and if you can spin both the writing
like that after you can do also the
particle interactions the strong
interactions and the weak interactions
and you can put the lot right and the
left together and I haven't done any of
this but it's a potential way of looking
at physics in a completely different way
well some of its being looked at already
people people have picked up on twister
theory but not on this latest idea they
use it for scattering problems massless
particles and things
but not to the extent that this would be
a global theory which you'd be able to
translate physics into this other
language and it has sort of features
which I appeal to me very much one of
them is the use of complex numbers you
see usually people think of numbers or
the integers 1 2 3 4 fractions which are
7 over 5 or whatever it is or real
numbers which write my decimal which
goes off to infinity so you tend to
think of physics in terms of real
numbers they're called real numbers
they're not real in the ordinary sense
of real but but they're real but they're
no more real than some other kinds of
numbers but the things called imaginary
numbers or complex numbers are things
were you allowed to have take the square
root of minus 1 and that's the key thing
you allowed to have a thinking called I
and that's the square root of minus 1
once you put that into it you have a
whole new but not that new it was many
centuries ago when the idea was
introduced but it's a whole different
way of looking at the world and the
thing about it is quantum mechanics
already looks at the world that way
quantum mechanics the states in quantum
mechanics involve these complex numbers
so the idea is that you bring that kind
of complex number geometry into the real
world on the classical world and it's
somehow the quantum class will get a
little mixed up and it's a different way
of looking at things and there's very
beautiful mathematics in the complex
world if you like which you don't see in
the real world
and it's something which when I was an
undergrad and mathematics undergraduate
I was absolutely stunned by the magic
there is in these complex complex number
mean it's got a real number and imagine
you number together in the same number
and the algebra and the analysis and all
that stuff and the geometry of these
numbers has an elegance which you don't
see in the real number dormitory so it
always struck me as you know wouldn't it
be nice if somehow that was what
governed the world and that's what
twister theory does it gives you a
complex number picture real and
imaginary together picture of the world
which involves quantum ideas as well as
classical ones but the new idea where
the googley problem seems to be solved I
haven't had a chance to look at it very
seriously that's your next challenge yes
the next problem yes but I give up on
cosmology well I don't think do the both
it was but there's so many new things in
the cosmology that need to be thought
about for more debates talks and
interviews subscribe today to the
Institute of Arts and ideas at IAI TV
you